good evening my name is Megan Kane and I
am a senior rhetoric in public address
major from Omaha Nebraska tonight I have
the pleasure of introducing this evening
speaker
Anthony slide Anthony slide is a film
historian and author a former associate
archivist of the American Film Institute
and resident film historian of the
Academy of Motion Pictures Arts and
Sciences he has authored or edited more
than 250 books on the history of popular
entertainment in recognition of his work
on the history of American popular
culture mr. Slyde received an honorary
doctorate of letters from Bowling Green
University his books the American film
industry a historical dictionary and the
encyclopedia of vaudeville are awarded
rare word awarded outstanding reference
source of the Year by the American
Library Association he is also the
editor of it's the pictures that got
small Charles Brackett on Billy Wilder
in Hollywood's golden age please join me
in welcoming Anthony slide
[Applause]
hello again yeah well I'm ready for my
close-up and and I can't help thinking
when I heard that this talk was going to
be streamed I I wondered how Billy
Wilder and Doris Swanson would have
thought you know how many years later 50
sets sixty-seven years later that we
would have streaming and we could see
movies anytime we want to do a totally
different age anyway enough of that I
met Billy Wilder once we had dinner
he and his then collaborator I Al
Diamond back in night and my back in
1977 and this one might expect
it was dark Billy who dominated the
conversation I can recall are discussing
a newly released Paramount feature film
Black Sunday directed by John
Frankenheimer Billy noted that it was
better than any of the universal films
of the same genre there was a pause the
sort of pregnant pause that only a vac
and Terra such as Billy Wilder could
deliver and he continued but then any
film is better than something produced
by Universal well Billy Wilder worked at
Universal only once as a lighter but
during the period we now identify as a
Golden Age of Hollywood he did work at
Paramount with Charles Brackett as his
writing partner and then as both his
writing partner and producer there was a
period in the early 1950s when Billy did
not have a permanent collaborator not
that the lack of one prevented his
making such classics as a sin the whole
star like seventeen Sabrina and the
seven-year itch but he really seemed
consciously or unconsciously to need
someone at his side and certainly I al
is he diamond served that purpose from
1957 onwards as the two turned out
scripts for substance films as some like
it heart the apartment and a dozen more
new titles while diamond did not
function in the capacity of a producer
Billy and he did have a permanent
production producer in the Mirage
brothers first how old nourish and then
water mimmish I'm here to talk a billy
wilder and Hollywood's golden age and in
so doing I must also talk of Charles
Brackett it was Hollywood's golden age
and it was a golden age for both men and
as I look at Billy's later post Brackett
career I see links back to that golden
age water mimmish a fine gentleman a
good friend to me as well I might add I
edited his autobiography and very much
alive today he reminds me of Charles
Brackett Walter may be Jewish and
Charlie might have been Christian but
the two men were Billy's producer and
both might be considered a senior
statesman in the Hollywood community
we've both serving as long-term
presidents of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences so I'm just
gonna try and figure out the best way to
see the script with the lighting okay so
I do need to see the script so how did
Billy achieve his exalted place in
Hollywood history as one of the few
filmmakers whose name is instantly
recognizable not just two members of the
film establishment but also to the
general public
Billy Wilder was born in 1906 in a
remote corner of the Austrian Empire
garyun Empire which is now part of
Poland as Billy would joke it was half a
mile from Vienna by telegraph a few
years earlier Adolf Hitler also had been
born in Austria and just as the world
identified Hitler as German so did Billy
Wilder similarly is so is Billy Wilder
similarly identified as German in that
he began his film career as a
screenwriter in Berlin Billy's approach
to a career was not quite as ruthless as
that of Adolf Hitler but both men have
left their mark on history one in a good
way and one in a very bad way
it was Hitler the Nazis who forced Billy
to flee Germany in 90
33 and eventually to come the following
year to America
it was Hitler who killed Billy's mother
stepfather and grandmother in Auschwitz
let us not forget that Hitler was
Austrian Billy would often tell
interviewers and also Billy buy the
world was not by the way above
exploiting his early life recently I
found a listing at a paramount of all
the scripts they owned but which they
had never produced and among them I
found a title called birth of a hero
screenplay by Billy Wilder and Charles
Brackett we don't know when it was
written but obviously after 1939 the
plot basically is of a football player
of Polish descent who goes to Poland to
rescue his grandmother before the German
invasion but the Nazi blitzkrieg begins
and the old lady a fiery patriot enlists
the aid of her grandson and an American
Girl photographer to carry some of
Poland's gold reserves safely out of the
country
I assume Billy saw himself as the
American hero
it was Hitler's actions that indirectly
led to Billy's making five graves to
Kyllo a 1943 World War Two drama set in
the sands of Egypt - a Foreign Affair
released in 1948 a cynical examination
of a war ravaged Berlin and a cabaret
singer Marlena Dietrich who hides her
background as the mistress of a
high-ranking Nazi Billy had been sent to
Germany in 1945 to help with the Nazi
denazification program who else but
Billy Wilder could have found Nazi war
crimes a subject for humour Billy
returned to Germany at war with
star-like 17 in 1953 the semi comic
story of a group of American ham and
four-team the Nazis and a German
prisoner of war camp very realistic for
its time surprisingly and again in 1961
he was back in Germany with one two
three the weakest of what might be
called the German quartet with
capitalism represented by coca-cola
standing strong an American again
the Cold War and a divided Berlin
ironically the Berlin Wall began to be
built while Billy was actually filming
there on one two three despite what was
happening in Europe Billy was not above
joking about the war in April 1941 when
things looked bleak for Britain he
considered what might happen too hot in
Hollywood - Hollywood Jews when the
Nazis invaded he surmised MGM head Louie
B Meyer
would be smuggled into into Mexico in
the rumble seat of producer Arthur feeds
car Sam Goldwyn would be caught and
slaughtered in Bakersfield Billy didn't
like Sam Goldwyn never imagined
while Billy himself would find refuge on
a ranch
- which Charlie Brackett would send him
sixty-five cents worth of food a week
more seriously both billion and slue
[ __ ] believed that if Britain lost the
war within six months they and other
Jews would no longer be allowed to work
in the industry
the feeling was stoked by a general
opinion opinion that most Americans were
anti-semitic
and that communists in Hollywood were
pro-nazi thanks to the German Russian
non-aggression pact
Charlie Brackett in fact recorded actor
John Garfield whom he described as a
real stinker talking at lunch of his
hatred for England and his love of
Russia initially life was not easy for
Billy Wilder in Hollywood he had entered
America on a tourist visa and was forced
to cross the border into Mexico and we
apply for the permanent visa he used his
experience in part in the writing of
haulback the dawn in 1941 he had made at
least two decent films in Europe people
on Sunday a cinematic cinema verite look
at the life of ordinary Berliners in
1929 and Bad Seeds shot in France in
1934 and starring Danielle derriere but
his reputation did not follow him to
America Billy Wilder's life changed on
August the 17th 1936
when paramount decided that he was to be
to be teamed as a screenwriter
with Charles Brackett it was in fact a
life-changing event for both men Charlie
Brackett had a reputation as a novelist
a short story writer and feared a critic
for The New Yorker he was a member of
the Algonquin Round Table but he had
made little of having impact as a
screenwriter in Hollywood
the two men were different as it is
perhaps possible to be Brackett was an
Episcopalian the skien of a wealthy New
England family a product of the Harvard
Law School a Republican whose ancestors
had come to America in the 1600s he was
erudite intelligent and what might be
described in crude terms as a wasp a
white anglo-saxon Protestant Billy
Wilder was Jewish a former journalist a
Democrat and someone whose grasp of
English was not always perfect
he once complained that English is a
tough language because sir know too many
letters in the words they are were
letters that are totally useless there
was a kind of improbability about Wilder
he was already world worthy he was a
hypochondriac when somebody else had a
heart attack he would rush immediately
to the offices and his cardiologist and
to a large extent he was lazy he did not
take kindly to criticism from studio
executives he was in the world words of
Charles Brackett I quote a neurotic
genius who craved persecution unquote
Billy was a notorious womanizer
Charlie was married perhaps not happily
and remained faithful to a wife who
suffered from mental problems and
alcoholism when it came to relationships
Billy could be very Cavalier in his
attitude when Brackett got excited over
the presence of Marlena Dietrich and the
restaurant at a restaurant in which the
couple were eating wild distorted quote
Marlena
if the waiters were to wheel over a big
covered dish with her in its stark-naked
I'd say not interest
and have him wheel other way the story
is told of bill is receiving a letter
from a farmer lady friend with whom he'd
had a brief affair he tore it up not
even bothering to read it and then he
retrieved a piece of the gray colored
paper noting it was exactly the color
heater the perfect shade for his
bathroom wall paramount was one of the
major Hollywood studios of the era
boasting such stars at one time or
another as Pola Negri Gloria Swanson who
you just saw Clara Bow Mae West
Claudette Colbert Marlena Dietrich WC
Fields and Molly Chevalier it had some
of the best directors under contract
Cecil B DeMille who again you just saw
Josef von Sternberg Ernst Lubitsch who
also served as power man's head of
production
Mitchell Ison Rouben Mamoulian and
Preston Sturges
Metro go will may or might claim that it
in more stars in Hollywood in heaven I'm
sorry but paramount at least in my
opinion could have boasted that it had
more creative and original stars under
contract not only stars but original and
creative directors and original and
creative writers in particular the team
of Walter and Brackett
how about operated very much as a family
and I think you get that no shot you
watching Sunset Boulevard when Norma
Desmond comes to the studio there is
really an very nice atmosphere there
they were all welcoming back
some of in the past they still remember
they still adore she means a great deal
to them part was a comfortable studio in
which to work it nurtured creativity
writers such as bracket and Wilder did
not work set set hours didn't clock in
they arrived at the studio whenever was
convenient to them they would seldom
work before lunch preferring perhaps to
discuss the films they might have seen
the previous evening together or
separately lunch would be taken together
or separately in the studio commissary
or at Lucis restaurant across the road
from the studio on Melrose Avenue after
lunch
Charlie Brackett would generally take a
nap
on the daybed kindly provided by the
studio in the Culp couples multi room
office around 4 p.m. work might begin
often it would continue into the evening
after dinner at the home of one of the
other blighters working at the studio
Charlie would lie on the daybed a yellow
pad on his lap while Billy paced the
floor
usually with a riding crop in his hand
throwing out ideas or dialog the latter
which Charlie would translate into
understandable English he would then put
vitai on his yellow pad decipherable -
just about to nobody and these were
handed over to I'm sorry I'm getting
confused here were handed over to the
couple's indefatigable secretary Helen
Hernandez who would transcribe them in a
way I always see Helen Hernandez is
forgotten heroin in the Billy Wilder
Charles Brackett story Charlie quickly
realized that his temperamental partner
always had to originate an idea the
thing to do explain vac it was to
suggest an idea have it torn apart and
despised a few days later it would be
apt to turn up slightly changed as
Wilders idea once I got suggested to
this way of working our lives were much
simpler when we speak of Hollywood's
golden age we do not reference
independent or low-budget films of the
year but rather the films of the major
Studios films that were guaranteed an
audience simply because the studios
owned the theaters in which they played
and Americans routinely as a matter of
course went to the movies on a weekly
basis it didn't matter what was playing
the family went to the movies every
Monday night or every Saturday night or
whenever there were no flops in the
Golden Age every film found an audience
a captive one let us look at Paramount
Pictures as representative of that
Golden Age and let us look at Billy
Wilder and Charles Brackett because we
cannot really discuss water without
Brackett as exemplary of the creativity
of that Golden Age
if it's a paramount picture it's the
best show in town claimed the studio's
advertising slogan and indeed it was and
in a way it all began in 1929 when a
paramount film wings won the first
Academy Award for Best Picture a few
years later the studio had two of the
greatest writers in Hollywood under
contract Brackett and Wilder hailed by
Life magazine as the happiest couple in
Hollywood invalid reality they were
anything but like many a Hollywood
marriage it was a sham an arranged
marriage today screenwriters select
their partners but back then there was
no self selection it was the studio who
determined who your writing partner was
to be thankfully for us the viewing
public wilder and rakia stayed together
and flourished if not forever at least
for long enough to provide us with some
memorable films once Billy had started
directing and Charlie had started
producing the scripts that they wrote
together they became collective studio
rotors I know Billy doesn't like the
term auteur
but that's what they were very much
responsible for all aspects of the film
the casting the look the construction
whatever but this came later first it
was a writing partnership nothing more
or nothing less which we have no plans
for it to last for a decade or more the
first of the wilder bracket
collaborations was Bluebeard's last wife
on which the couple worked from 1936
through 1937 with the film going into
release in 1938 the leading players were
paramount stars Claudette Colbert and
Gary Cooper but more importantly the
director the sophisticated comedy about
a seven times married and divorced
millionaire was legendary German born
director Ernst Lubitsch it was always
maintained that his films did not take
place in America or Europe but rather in
Lew [ __ ] land a timeless country of
grace charm wisdom and sophistication
Lubitsch was a leading light of
Hollywood's golden age and importantly
he was a man of whom both wilder and
Racquet stood in awe when he died in
1947 Billy Wilder was a pallbearer at
his funeral and Racquet read the eulogy
when someone commented no more Lubitsch
Wilder responded worse no more Lubitsch
films thereafter Billy Wilder had a gold
faint sign of his wall across from his
desk it read simply how would Lubitsch
have done it it was Lubitz who taught
Billy Wilder how to do it
and he would often repeat a tip that
Lubitz had given to him never
underestimate the intelligence of the
audience I suppose in a way one might
argue that Hollywood's golden age ended
with the death of Ernst Lubitsch no war
Lubitsch films only dull reality and an
obsession with realism that was to be
reignited in the 1950s but that was
still a decade away for Billy Wilder as
he and Brackett were loaned by Paramount
to Universal to out a vehicle for deanna
durbin now in theory this might not
might sound like torture for the two men
working on a film for a child star who
was fast eclipsing Shirley Temple as
America's favorite young person but it
wasn't in large part because both men
actually liked deanna durbin who was
intelligent beyond her years and had a
healthy contempt for her career years
later in fact she described herself to
me as I quote synthetic old durbin of
the thirties and that's how she viewed
her films and her career what disturbed
the two men most was that Universal was
not paramount he was far from glamorous
in fact Charlie Blackie described it as
a friendly shabby little studio one
actress actually told me that her be
members of Universal was that it didn't
provide toilet paper so much of
Hollywood's golden age
vlad rick crawford whom some of you may
remember from televisions highway patrol
and the great 1949 biopic about you
along all the king's men once told me
that being under contract to universal
was quote like being stuck in a sewer
without voter looter in a way the
universal sojourn was a novella vain'
see in that waddle and bracket took
their names off the film owing to a
dispute is to the credit line the most
annoying aspect of the whole episode to
billy was that the film that certain age
which was really his in black it's film
got good reviews back at paramount the
couple worked on a Lubitsch like
production midnight with Claudette
Colbert masquerading as a Hungarian
countess in Parisian society it was
directed by Mitchell lisen who had some
of Lubitsch's qualities but was also
prissy argumentative and inclined to
interfere with the script midnight was
followed by a real Lubitsch film and one
of his most famous ninotchka a satire on
the cold war and Russian politics said
in Paris the worst part of ninotchka for
both water and racket was that it was
shot at MGM with the couple again on
loan out from paramount through July
1939 they didn't like the formality of
MGM they didn't like having to clock in
and Billy retaliated by deciding he had
the tumor of the vein and feigning a
nervous breakdown he was genuine and he
unhappy perhaps an understatement when
news of the German Russian pact was
announced and when on September 1st 1939
he heard on the radio of Germany's
bombardment of Poland with his
grandmother on the front line of the
attack on September 3rd 1939 the entire
company was devastated to learn of the
sinking by Nazi u-boats of the British
line of the Athenian on which aboard of
which was Lubitsch's 11 month-old
daughter happily she survived but the
Europe of which wardens a kid was joking
was under attack
and certainly the war had made a major
impact on Billy Wilder on November 10th
1940 Billy took care of his
naturalization papers he chose Charles
Brackett to accompany him I think mrs.
very important to stress because we read
so much about Wilder and brackets being
antagonistic towards each other but when
it came to becoming an American citizen
it was Charlie Brackett whom Billy
Wilder selected to be at his side he
didn't choose any of his German emigres
fence he didn't choose Lubitsch he chose
Charlie Bucket of course bakit had his
own opinion at middle European
immigrants such as Billy Wilder I quote
it seems to me that they've come into a
department store being crazy about its
stock put themselves down for a charge
account no more involvement than that
unquote ninotchka of course is
remembered as much for its star Greta
Garbo as its director or its script it
was the actresses penultimate film and
certainly one of her best at Billy
Wilder and Charlie Brackett had their
way Garbo's career would not have ended
they tried unsuccessfully to cast her to
the Anne Baxter Wald in five graves to
Carlo Bob Hope was under contract to
Paramount and in 1943 it was suggested
that he and Garbo teamed her comedy the
studio's liked the idea
Garbo did not nor do I've she may not
have been too enthusiastic about Bob
Hope but she admitted to being crazy
about Bing Crosby and in 1945 when
wilder and Brackett initially began work
on the Emperor waltz bill his first film
in color he much preferred to work in
black-and-white
Garbo actively considered coming out of
otama to play opposite Bing Crosby
she told wilder and Racquet how much she
liked them how much she liked the story
how much she loved the star but she had
a pathological fear of returning to the
screen she never did too bad
meanwhile vaca tan Wilder had been again
loaned out by Parliament now loan-outs
of contract artists brought in a healthy
income to Studios with the employee
receiving their regular salary and the
studio returning substantially more from
the lending Samuel Goldwyn was a
happiest happy recipient of the pair and
the film they wrote for him was ball of
fire a comedy about a burlesque dancer a
great role for Barbara Stanwyck who
moves in with a prissy college
professors maybe could be make it at
Hillsdale who wanted to help with an
encyclopedia they are completing on the
subject of slang what is fascinating is
that Brackett who was - well they're
educated for his own good and Walder who
had problems with the English language
actually created argot the sort of slang
which the burlesque dancer might be
familiar without Paramount's knowledge
wilder and Brackett later in 1947 were
to gain for bit what Goldwyn writing
scenes for the Bishop's wife which
starred Cary Grant hopelessly miscast in
the opinion of the two men while today
we remember Wilder vakidis relatively
forgotten but it's worth noting that at
Paramount brackets salary was several
times greater than that of Wilder
obviously it was a source of almost
constant irritation to walden and then
paramount came up with a solution wilder
should also direct the films he and
Beckett were lighting and he could be
paid more money that of course led to
bill is complaining that he was
directing for nothing and also led to
Beckett's complaining that he should be
paying more still so he was elevated to
the role of producer and again his
salary was ahead of that of his
colleague is that a true story is that
how Billy Wilder became a director in
all probability at least according to
Charles Baggett it is but the official
Billy Wilder version is that he was
unhappy with changes that director
Mitchell lisen had made to the script of
holdback the dawn
he decided the solution was for him to
direct the next film the couple vote in
1942 the major and the minor a film
which wanted its audience to believe
that Ginger Rogers could pass as a
twelve-year-old girl it was actually
well received and is still entertaining
today and of course sexual deception and
sexual repression are major themes in
Billy Wilder's films it's the major in
the minor is perhaps not the most
propitious start to a directorial career
that has become legendary but they're
not exactly a bad start simply not a
very memorable one and there's the same
toddler with Billy's next film 5 graves
to kylo then it's almost as if Billy
Wilder hits his stride as a director and
the next two films will heavily impact
his career and his standing with critics
and later historians most of what had
come before was commonly but here
handing to serious subjects Billy shows
his versatility both as a director and a
screenwriter the Double Indemnity
released in April 1944 Billy had a new
and most unsatisfactory collaborator in
novelist Raymond Chandler there has been
much speculation as to why Brackett and
Wilder temporarily split but it is in
all probability not as traumatic as some
might have one believe the two men
actually wrote the first treatment of
double indemnity together and Charlie
actually helped with some of the
dialogue for the film there were days
actually when Billy was on the set he
was he knew he had problems with the
script to the next day he couldn't
contact Raymond Chandler so he asked
Charlie to help out and Charlie did but
Charlie recorded that Billy was quote
having a touch of claustrophobia working
with him and it was time for a break
which he approved and he probably took a
certain delight in the ecstasy of
torture as he called it that was working
with Raymond Chandler regardless as you
allure from tomorrow speaker Alan
silver and tomorrow's screening Double
Indemnity is the work of a great
director and a production that defines
film noir the last weekend released more
than a year later is arguably one of the
most important of the wild a bracket
films at Paramount it is based on a
best-selling novel by Charles Jackson
who consistently tried to interfere with
the production and was and it was
despised by both wilder and bracket the
book was published in 1944 the same year
as the film began production The Lost
Weekend won the Academy Award for Best
Picture an award which bakit points out
that he should have received rather than
paladin an executive in new Young's burg
Best Actor Best Screenplay a first for
black Eden wilder and other Oscars
perhaps most notably best film editing
for Beckett and wild as longtime and
long-suffering collaborator Dwayne
Hanson it was not the initial choice of
either black heed or water at that time
a neither man appeared to have taken the
last weekend's theme of her alcoholism
very seriously when they were told of
opposition to the film than both
Alcoholics Anonymous and the allied
liquor industry's vak Eden Wilder Seward
the former that they would not argue
that a psychiatrist was necessary to an
alcoholics cure as a feared the liquor
industry was informed that the track
Eden water will do receive a case of
scotch each week in perpetuity they were
managed quote to make the spectators
lick their lips unquote back even Wilder
celebrated the end of shooting on
December 23rd 1944 by distributing
liquor to the crew on the set the day
after the Academy Awards vaca didn't
Wilder arrived to Paramount to find the
writers building garland II with those
of whiskey bottles at a final studio
celebration on March 11th 1946 in the
coma c-bracket was presented with a
present of a whiskey bottle surrounded
by sleeping tablets a tube of morphine
and a hypodermic needle
and finally this is my favorites toy it
must be reported in May 1945 the last
weekend had a preview in San Bernardino
California
it was marred by the projectionists
being drunk and screening the wheels out
of order something which apparently the
audience didn't notice while don't like
it may not have cared too much about the
film but we see here their ongoing power
at the studio they approved the
replacement of leading man Cary Grant
with Ray Milland
Jane Wyman was always their choice for
female lead but paramount initially
balked at paying the $40,000 fee asked
by Warner Brothers had had her under
contract Dorothy Lamour was free the
studio suggested Billy and Charlie
discussed the matter a little frightened
but they got Wyman as they wanted and
the only major problem was that Jane
Wyman nipples were clearly visible
through her sweater in one scene and
speaking of sexual matters much to
Beckett's annoyance Wilder cast his
mistress Doris Dowling in a relatively
prominent role Brackett denounced her
performance as amateurish an accused
wilder of being too afraid to tell us oh
by the way if you're going to be
partaking of a glass of wine or
something stronger after my talk I would
like you to raise a glass
not only to Billy Wilder but couple it
with a toast to the Lost Weekend by the
late 1940s the film industry was
changing as far as I am concerned the
Golden Age was about over the government
consent decree which had taken many
years and endless lawsuits to become
reality meant in the studio's had to
divest themselves of their theaters they
no longer had a guaranteed home for
their films no guaranteed audience the
studio system itself was failing and the
end was in sight when Studios could no
longer keep stars and creative personnel
under long-term contract
television would soon become the viewing
public smedium of choice
no more weekly visits to the movers
paramount pictures were no longer the
best show of town in town the late 1940s
also saw the birth of the McAfee here
with the anti-communist witch hunts
affecting Hollywood which had never
really been immune from public politics
generally left-wing when ten
screenwriters refused to testify before
the House Committee on American
activities they were arrested in 1950
and granted the Hollywood ten or the
unfriendly ten Billy Wilder quipped one
or two of them were talented the rest
were just unfriendly Billy himself tried
to keep above politics perhaps aware of
his immigrant status he was the liberal
and his attitude towards communism is
apparent from ninotchka
the film character tchard the wood cold
war just as later the Emperor waltz was
depowered was a parody of the
austro-hungarian Empire into which he
had been born perhaps the only really
real political stance he took was when
he he opposed the enforcement of a
loyalty oath for members of the Screen
Directors Guild in fact about the only
evidence of Billy's having any strong
politics political beliefs or vases
views is contained in an argument with
his wife Judith he told her too far the
couple's african-american servants
because they were lazy and to make sure
their replacements were white
because all diggers are lazy
Judith angrily responded you can't say
that any more than you can say all Jews
a shysters and cheats in reply Wilder
said the only generation generalization
one can make is that all capitalists are
sons of [ __ ] happy day in the Wilder
household the partnership of Billy
Wilder and Charlie Beckett was coming to
its conclusion what had been an average
was no longer even a friendship the
arguments and ill feelings increased
there was even violence when Billy
thought a flute into the office insist
in insisting on constantly playing it
only to have Charlie grab the instrument
from his hands put it across his knee
and snap it into there was no more work
that day
Billy's marriage to his first wife
Judith came to an end and in 1948 he
married his second wife Audrey Charlie
didn't approve the bill his mistresses
he liked Judith and he did not like
Audrey one of those many mistresses and
also being the golden age to a close was
the greatest film that wilder and vac
had made and the film generally
considered to be Billy's best as a
director of course Sunset Boulevard here
is the film the positively declares war
on its audience as it depicts a
hollywood that hollywood did not want to
reveal it might be melodramatic at times
but Sunset Boulevard is a film unlike
any of the earth they're happy
depictions of life in the film industry
and in the honey and in Hollywood it's a
film that combines the cynicism wit and
sheer nastiness of Billy Wilder with a
romanticism and glorification of the
past so close to the heart of Charlie
Brackett the golden age was over both
Brackett and Wilder continued to prosper
with Charlie's becoming a senior
producer at 20th Century Fox and Billy
making one successful film after another
through the years in a way
Billy Wilder acknowledged his death to
write a bracket by insisting that films
were quote authored unquote and that the
direction should take place in the
writing it was the words that mattered
and it is the words of Norma Desmond in
Sunset Boulevard written by Wilder that
resonate through the years in his career
I quote will make another picture and
another and another you see this is my
life it always will be
thank you
Thank You mr. slide has agreed to assign
copies of the book it's the pictures
that got small Charles Brackett on Billy
Wilder in Hollywood Golden Age you're
actually following the lecture in
Phillips Lobby we now have time for a
few questions please raise your hand and
wait for a microphone to be brought to
you I know now we have people that are
classified as great producers great
directors and great writers yet fewer
and fewer do we see combination writer
directors or writer producers would you
classify Billy Wilder was basically
started out as a writer and they became
a writer director did he do films that
were written by others no he didn't I
don't think well certainly not while he
was in Hollywood anyway but I think also
is it's you can't it's not a matter of
just classifying say Billy as one thing
I think you have to group him and what
and back it together and creatively they
are great producers writers and
directors and just as later you have say
water marish ial Dimond and billy wilder
and they're great writers directors and
producers yes I think so
yes I mean I think the back end and
Wilder needed each other they obviously
I mean initially I I added Charlie
Brackett star is and when the diary
entry for his first meeting with Billy
Wilder doesn't contain very much of
interest but he appended a note that he
wrote a dozen years later in which he
talks about how important he realized
that moment was in his career so so yes
I think it was important to black I
don't think I'd everything Wilder Billy
thought that much about he was just
happy to have a contract with Paramount
and so who he was working with initially
didn't really matter but because we
don't know what goes on for the men's
minds but since at some point they must
have realized they needed each other
and you know as I sure you're gonna if
it's Alan Silver's talking isn't it you
Alan silver oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
forward I'm talking to something else
okay I'm stop talking to you that Oh No
okay so I'm sorry no but I'm I was going
to say that Billy Wilder finds out earn
as I Lancel tell us tomorrow and that
working with Raymond Chandler having a
new collaborator was not and that great
an experience and maybe he was better
because Charlie Brackett could you talk
a bit about how the industry reacted to
Sunset Boulevard given what a
devastating satire about the industry it
is I don't think the industry was at all
happy Louie be mayor was outraged
it's strange in a way because one would
assume something like Hedda Hopper also
would being a representative the
industry with her gossip column you know
what she would be outraged as well but
then of course she agreed to appear in
the film in large part because she was
such a close friend of Charlie brackets
and yet again here we had that strange
anomaly in Hollywood we have Charlie
Brackett who is no I'm sorry it's not an
anomaly at all it's actually because
Charlie Brackett is a conservative and
Hedda Hopper is a conservative there
aren't that many conservatives in
Hollywood so when two of them get
together they really get together so I
think that's why I had to hop who agreed
to be in the film I haven't really
answered your question but but no the
film industry was not happy at all with
the film Sunset Boulevard I think I also
things I couldn't say earlier for
example you have to remember that Gloria
Swanson wasn't that old when she made
the film she's not as old as Norma
Desmond is supposed to be and in fact
when they asked her to to appear as a 50
year old woman she said but I mean done
is older than I am why don't you cast I
ain't done in the part so but I think
she I think get again I'm sorry I'm not
answering your question but I'm pointing
out being a politician here I'm twisting
the questions around to what I want to
say so in but in a way I think you have
to earn model response after taking on
this role and you know and giving such a
magnificent performance
why do you think the film didn't win
more Awards I'm sorry why did well I
think in its glorious arts was of course
nominated for the Best Actress for her
goal but they eventually went to Anne
Baxter for All About Eve no I'm sorry
Judy
okay I'm sorry I'm stand corrected
anyway the point is Louis France didn't
win Best Actress that she really should
have done but and in fact the only award
that Sunset Boulevard one was for Best
Original Screenplay which went to packet
Walter and Don Marshman so I so in a way
it was popular with members of the film
establishment who are not maybe the
heads of studios or major producers but
the ordinary men and women who vote for
the Academy Awards but ultimately it
didn't make that much of an impact at
the Academy Award Show winning only one
award I'm sorry I haven't really
answered your question you make the
remark on the Hollywood ten you made the
remark on the Hollywood ten which seemed
to suggest that we were unfair to the
Hollywood ten I would think that the
Hollywood ten liked Stalin's Russia and
I don't think that I think two morally
condemned that it's justified well first
of all I don't think I was that sort of
positive about the Hollywood ten I was
actually making a joke about them but I
don't think the Hollywood ten first of
all had much of an impact on Hollywood
politics at all they were on the whole
extreme left-wing yes people like John
Howard Lawson for example who was a
known communist I mean you know when I
say known communists was somebody who
admitted to being a communist quite
openly but you're getting into a whole
other area you're asking me to say was
it was it was America justified
persecuting screenwriters for their
political views and I don't think the
answer is yes but at the same time I
think an awful lot of fuss was being
made about these 10 men who weren't very
important okay all right good Thank You
mr. slide okay thank you
[Applause]